he was one of the original American
Playboy's a magazine tycoon who helped
spark a revolution one that challenged
the nation's views on sexuality I have
celebrated the romantic connection
between the sexes and that's part of
what play was all about Hugh M Hefner
who liked to be called Hef was born in
Chicago in 1926 and raised in what he
said was a strict household by
conservative Protestant parents I felt
there was something more to life than
the world I saw around me in 1953 with
just $8,000 the aspiring publisher
produced the very first issue of Playboy
magazine on the kitchen table of his
Chicago apartment the cover featured a
photo of Marilyn Monroe and sold more
than 50,000 copies when it hit
newsstands in December of 1953 Hefner
now had the funds to finance another
issue and the Playboy Empire was born
well I have never really thought of
playboy as a sex magazine yeah what I've
tried to do is create a lifestyle
magazine for men Hefner divorced his
wife Mildred Williams in 1959 and during
the early days of the magazine success
decided he would not only promote the
fantasy he helped create but he would
live it as well
audience has got a taste of Hefner's
good life in an early 1960s television
show called Playboy's penthouse having
already established himself in Chicago
Hefner made the move out west in the
early 1970s when Playboy magazine was
selling 7 million copies a month he made
his permanent home at the now famous
Playboy Mansion in Los Angeles in 1989
Hefner uttered the two words many
thought he'd never say again when he
married Playmate of the Year
Kimberly Conrad the couple had two
children but separated in 1998 Hefner
said he realized he was much happier as
a bachelor I am essentially a romantic
so I think my life revolves and always
has revolves around women Hefner
continued to live out the playboy
fantasy even in his later years often
seen in his trademark silk pajamas
surrounded by busty blonde
lingerie clad women while hosting
extravagant parties with celebrity
guests he even returned to television in
2005 this time sharing the small screen
with three live-in girlfriends in the
reality show The Girls Next Door in the
late 2000s he began an on-again
off-again relationship with playmate
Crystal Harris 60 years his junior
they tied the knot on New Year's Eve in
2012 Hefner sold his beloved Playboy
Mansion for a hundred million dollars in
2016 on the condition that he be allowed
to live there for the rest of his life
Playboy and provocateur Hugh Hefner
wanted to make the world a happier
sexier place what's your definition of
obscenity racism war bigotry but sex
itself no what does what a sad and cold
world this would be if we weren't sexual
beings I mean that's the heart of who we
are